st les instituteurs du petit colon bas
quartiers de colombes dans les
hauts-de-seine se mobilisent contre la
misère ou du moins contre les conditions
de vie misérables de 23 familles de ce
quartier dont ils ont en charge les
enfants et devant la fatigue de certains
de leurs élèves les instituteurs ont
mené l enquête
voyez ce qu'ils ont découvert à leur
porte avec enquêtes de philippe le
boulanger intérieure au petit colombes
avec insalubrité une pièce cuisine salle
de bain pour huit personnes
les enfants dorment à terre sur des
couvertures humidité froid saleté un
logement de misère pour des gens
solvables loyer mensuel mille francs une
situation intenable qui a fait réagir
les instituteurs de l'école voisine a
cédé un style qui nous aident
heureusement mais avant il y avait
personne
on part à la à la mairie c'est la
préfecture la préfecture c'est la mairie
on est comme un ballon de fautes
les instits de l'école buffon ont tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé 26 familles à
majorité immigrées sont concernés les
problèmes scolaires de ses élèves sont
directement lié à ses conditions de vie
depuis novembre ils se sont jetés dans
la bataille
il héberge certains enfants et leur
comité de défense fait du bruit auprès
des administrations nous font disent
qu'il ya urgence avant loger sa famille
il faut savoir que ça fait plusieurs
années 80 en location la peine depuis
plus de 15 ans vivent dans des taudis
jusqu'à présent elles ont pu cacher leur
misère elle pas qu elle demande aux
autorités politiques et plus de vista
chiens nous ont réagi en est une autre a
salué en deux mois ça a bougé la mairie
de colombes et la préfecture des
hauts-de-seine ont promis de reloger
chacune 13 familles promesses en partie
tenues pour la mairie qui se réfugient
derrière ces programmes de
réhabilitation du côté préfecture calme
plat on travaille
nous avons 13 familles pour lesquelles
nous nous sommes engagés de les reloger
actuellement cinq le sont déjà à quatre
sont en instance de l'être d'ici fin
janvier
et nous allons voir mais nous pensons
quand même que les 13 autres c'est la
responsabilité du département
ce que je peux dire c'est que sur
colombes les 13 prochaines vacances qui
se déclareront qui correspondront bien
sûr la taille des familles à leurs
caractéristiques leur seront réservés en
priorité et je crois que dans les
quelques heures qui viennent nous serons
d'ailleurs en mesure de proposer un
premier logement
les instituteurs ne veulent plus
attendre leurs comités d'abord dénommé
de soutien à la municipalité pour leur
logement s'appelle maintenant comité des
mal-logés tout court aujourd'hui ils
font la grève du vote ils ont envoyé au
ciel leur carte d'électeur en mettant
tout leur poids dans la balance